Hi everyone.
I am Balázs Horváth and today I will
talk to you about what is the last thing
that AI will take away from us as people
in the software business. So, at a point
where writing code is no longer the
bottleneck, the real thing is to figure
is figuring out what it is that you
should be building.
Um and that comes down to to people
skills and being able to work the room
because you can't prompt the room. You
can prompt your AI.
So, at the beginning of the year, we
held an internal hackathon uh where we
had about 21 agents uh agent ideas and
17 of those were abandoned because they
actually created no um
business value.
They uh
um we either didn't have uh data access
or or it just didn't make sense uh to
build it. And those four were the ones
that actually had a very big impact on
how we work today.
And
it's it's a very good example of
of just making sure that we are building
what is worth building.
And throughout my career in the past 13
years, I've always been
uh the bridge between business and IT
and the developers.
Um
I started writing, well, initially
testings
uh
uh functional designs, specifications,
and then uh and then I wrote them. And
as uh as a functional consultant, I
worked with large ERP and CRM programs
in the US and the UK. And then I founded
Visual Labs.
And essentially,
I trained my my team on how to elicit
those requirements in a way
uh that we can turn them into good
uh specifications for developers to
build, for consultants to configure, and
most recently now for AI to build.
And what's not really changed over the
years is how we interact with our
customers, how we interact with systems,
how we interact with AI is very much
changing.
Um and that's that's uh that's the big
thing now.
Uh but if you can read the room, if you
can elicit the right requirements,
uh then you will be able to build more
valuable software.
And
that essentially the big shift over the
past 2 3 years was that getting access
to code and being able to build is no
longer the bottleneck to the software
development life cycle. Now the real
bottleneck is getting your people, your
stakeholders, your decision-makers into
the room and being able to access them
and elicit the requirement and being
able to spend the time with them. So
that's the right That's the real
bottleneck, figuring out what it is that
should be built. Cuz you can prompt your
code, you can prompt your AI, you can
prompt your whole specification, but you
can't prompt your room.
And
what a model can't do is very similar to
how Henry Ford's analogy of
what he said about asking his users or
his customers, if he'd asked them what
it is that they needed, they would have
said they needed more horses. But in
reality, he built a car and he made a
perfect success of them.
So if you're just using AI
um to to make things, you know, build
things better,
um the chances are that you are
replicating what already exists because
AI by definition is coded to give you
the most common answers. So for So for
us, the real job is to make sure that AI
moves away from that average into what
is better for us. So, we can just got to
not a faster horse, but actually produce
a car that's a magnitude shift better
than what we had.
So,
it's really an interesting word world
where
being able to write good code is no
longer
the most important skill to have.
Actually, the real skill now is becoming
the analysis analysis toolkit,
which is things like story mapping,
business model canvas,
value canvas, and those those good old
things that we are so used to using as
functional consultants, business
analysts,
or or uh
in in the world of design thinking.
So,
I'd like to zoom in on story mapping
because that's the the skill set that I
found as the most valuable.
So,
once you have the story map with the
backbones and understand at each step
what your customers, your users are
doing, that would give them the ability
to
to move forward
in their in their processes. So,
here's a
support systems user story map
contacting, triaging, resolving, and
then essentially closing a case.
With this,
you can understand different stages of
the process, and then capture the user
stories beneath them. It is intended to
stay at a fairly high level so you can
get a
a big picture, and then in you can
decide
what it is that you want to build and
release one like capturing intent,
classifying urgency, drafting a grounded
answer, and then logging logging it to a
system of record. That's essentially
your MVP. Those are the first things
that you'd want to build, and those are
your first four user stories. And
beneath those, you've got the
the second set of user stories, like
reading a sentiment, writing to a team,
suggesting next action, chatting
checking satisfactions, so on and so
forth.
Those will be part of your backlog. So,
what it would allow you to
to get really good
results is by honing in on these user
stories and making sure that you use
these user stories as a means
to elicit discussions with your
stakeholders, with your business, and
then work out what that user story
should really be about. So, the first
user story
second user story would be as a support
lead, I need to open cases ranked by
urgency so that none of the escalations
should slip. So, just make sure that
every user story covers these is ideally
written in this setup because AI is
really good at pattern recognition and
it was actually trained on the user
story structure because it's a very
well-known and well-used
setup. So, if you go back to something
that's familiar to AI, it will get get
you better better results.
And every user story
is actually made up with of these, you
know, well-known structures, the
persona, the what, the actual need, and
the why. So, by
packaging these up and giving it to AI,
obviously with the acceptance criteria
based on which you can derive the test
cases, you will be able to create very
good setup and very good
very good results. And then if you just
connect these user stories, daisy chain
them up, then that will allow you to
create a coherent system based on which
you can create your specification and
then essentially your code. So, the
software development life cycle doesn't
change as much as a result of AI. It's
actually the toolkit that we are we are
using is changing.
Right. So,
when we
uh
work with systems and when we think
about what we want to build, I always
like to ask these four questions as
whose problem is this? Whose problem are
we actually solving? So, we can we can
name it to a direct person, direct
persona,
uh and it's very much quantified.
What does winning look like for them?
So, when are they actually successful?
Are they achieving the right outcome? Uh
can we help them achieve that right
outcome
uh in a quick way or a smooth way or a
safe way?
And what would that make make them
refuse to use it? It's not available on
their platform, it's cumbersome to use,
it's uh the data security aspect
applies, so they would wouldn't actually
use it.
And
would it change a decision? Ideally, we
want to be impacting how a person makes
a decision and we'd want to, you know,
tilt them to making better decisions.
So, does it change a decision and and
what is the decision that it changes?
So, once you can answer these four
questions, then you'll be able to elicit
better responses from your AI and just
make sure that you track all of these in
a good old markdown file in your
repository so that AI can access it. It
will just get way more context out of
it.
And
you know, if you just did something as
generic as build us an agent that
handles support, uh you will not get the
answer you want. So,
what we always do is go from value, so
understand how value is created, what
constitutes value,
how the process currently flows, what is
the underlying architecture beneath it
that supports that process, and then you
can and then you can start the actual
design where you can start designing.
So, we like to call this uh thinking
process VAD, value architecture design,
and this is what we want to always go
through. So, always have, you know,
value in mind, how we're creating value,
what is the value we are creating, what
is the value that your customer is
looking for, what is the underlying
process that supports this, and how you
can design a system around it so it best
supports the value and the process, and
what process changes are needed along
the way.
So, you might ask, isn't this just good
old product management?
And to certain extent, yes, it is an old
skill, it is an old trade that is worth
picking up and learning, because this is
now becoming uh the mode, if you will,
of how you can elicit the right
requirements, how you can build better
software, because we all have access to
the same tools, so the difference will
be who can understand the business need
better,
uh because then we can all just uh have
the latest and greatest model write the
code for us. So, it's old skill, but new
economics, and it's a real shift towards
analyst toolkit.
So,
what building the wrong thing looks
like, if you've got velocity of your
shifting shipping new features like
crazy, uh but the adoption is not good.
If people are barely using it, that's
actually a very very poor pattern,
that's what you want to address. Um if
people are trying out new features,
they're logging into the new system, we
just wiped Google it out, craziest
newest thing, but they are not actually
reusing it. So, don't look at time of
usage and time spent on site.
Much rather you got look at the
frequency of a certain activity.
Um, if another uh miss pattern and
anti-pattern is if the demo is the
deliverable. We want to make sure that
people can
can put things into production. It's
really fast to do a demo and it will
look nice, but people aren't actually
using it. So, the demo system is not a
live system.
And
if your PRD has no real user testers, so
if you if you don't gather proper
feedback uh from a real user, then it's
chances are it will not make it into
into a live environment and people will
not use it.
So,
uh the big thing here is is actually
putting your you know your everything is
needs to be moving upstream here. Uh so,
uh earlier on before the AI boom,
uh we had our smartest people writing
our code, but what now we need to be
shifting our smartest people towards our
customers, towards the business
problems, and we need to be spending
more time on deciding what to build
because that's the expensive part.
Building it has actually become very
cheap.
So, couple of things that you can start
doing from Monday morning or from the
next day is
audit the wrong thing, right? Just start
figuring out what are the wrong things
that you're currently tracking.
And and just make sure that you are
realigning your measurements, your time,
what what it is that you're looking for.
So, uh the number of features shipped
last quarter,
that should be
should be eliminated and you should just
start looking at the number of features
that we shipped that is actually used
more than twice. So, that would be a
good
a good shift in your KPIs and your
metrics.
And just make sure that you're moving
those real subject matter experts to a
more customer-facing, client-facing
role or position where they have an
actual impact on what gets built.
And I'm not suggesting that everybody
should become a functional consultant or
a product manager, product owner. I'm
just saying involve them in the
decision-making because they have the
most experience of what worked in the
past and what didn't. And just making
sure that gets included in the
decision-making of what should be built
is a super important aspect. And I still
do this
I recommend it to everyone to actually
start doing a mapping session before you
build.
Just make sure that you either create a
user story map or business model canvas
or any old mapping that highlights where
the value lives and just make sure that
you understand
how you create value. So,
um
I hope you found this valuable. It's a
lots of lots of old things stitched
together
that will really make a difference. Just
give it a shot if you have a good use
case that you want to wipe code. Try
building it with user stories first or
without user stories and just compare
the difference in the results.
When I did this for myself,
that was the big big shift that I
started doing is holy cow, I still need
to incorporate user stories
in my development. So this way we can
build the right thing and not just the
next thing.
Um
You can
scan a QR code to connect with me on
LinkedIn. I would be happy to chat
further. Thank you so much.